[Musik]
und das muss jetzt immer speziell
betonen dass das nicht noch mal
verschieden exil wo er jetzt gilt als
erfinder von paparazzi alex
[Musik]
sie stürzte
hanery amman seine lieder sind bekannt
dass er standard werke des mundart druck
[Musik]
man kämpft seit jahren mit lungenkrebs
trotzdem spielte fast jedes wochenende
ein konzert
[Musik]
ziel muss sein
stark
[Musik]
von der kraft von der liebe zur musik
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
[Applaus]
uni spital zürich
hier wurde er andere mit bürgerlichem
namen hans peter nach langen
leidensweges lungenflügel entfernt
ich begleite ihn zur letzten kontrolle
das programm findet sie sehr gut
die klage der arbeit ja fast schon
gewöhnlich sehr gut
oder was mehr wenn sie deren höhe die
wollen wir die kaputte lose geweckt
dann wird das über druck und das tut not
während das jetzt wieder mit dem rücken
oder einfach einfach als ein von den
atomeinstieg der jahreswagen auf denen
antibiotika ja jetzt haben wir das ganz
vergessen ist unsere identität der
infekte die shrek oder transit medizin
wieder hinter sich
[Musik]
interlaken hier ist hamann vor 64 jahren
geboren
hier wohnt er noch heute im touristenort
betreibt er seit den 80er jahren ein
eigenes tonstudio in seinem refugium
hatte wohl hunderte stunden musik
aufgenommen aber nach rumpelstilz nur
zwei eigene alben veröffentlicht das
letzte erschien vor 17 jahren
[Musik]
nun wagt einen neuen versuch mit dem
gips aus seiner jugend außerdem arbeitet
er an einem instrumental musik projekt
verschoben
[Musik]
da half dann müsse er aber das groove
attack mit groove der blues
[Musik]
trotz der euphorie frage ich mich bei
diesem besuch ob auch diese aufnahmen
der einst im archiv verstauben
warum nur an ria man über all die jahre
seine kompositionen so spärlich
veröffentlicht
[Musik]
kommen jetzt einfach ist völlig trocken
so dass sich damit nämlich mache gute
kontakt und da machen roboter job
mitbekommt sagt mache dass haye macht ob
neue image bild das volk also willkommen
das ist ja das ist das ist offen wo die
gags machen sie ist nicht gleich
vergleichbar mit dem dank aber nach
freddie
der goldene anker in interlaken man
wohnt gleich über dem altehrwürdigen
konzertlokal wir brechen auf zu einem
weiteren big eine halbe autostunde
entfernt er ist spät dran
andrea mann hat einmal mehr kaum
geschlafen ein permanentes rauschen im
ohr ein tinnitus von 65 dezibel
lautstärke hält ihn oft davon ab diesen
hatte nicht wegen zu lauter musik
sondern aufgrund einer missglückten
operation die das system nach größe
trotz all dieser schicksalsschläge etwas
die nimmer über wasser gehalten
die liebe zur musik bekommen kann das
klavier bekommen
mit 2 goals einfach zu sagen
[Musik]
der täter schlug
diese offensive und spielt er ja neu
gemacht will
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie erfahren
heißen soll
[Musik]
das spiel
mutter
[Musik]
das war sie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
rosmarin
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zwei stunden auf der bühne mit nur einem
lungenflügel
das zehrt
[Musik]
doch kaum hat sich der pianist erholt
wird der backstage zum alleinunterhalter
die bahn nicht ob und wo siehst du auf
[Musik]
seit 40 jahren die gleichen songs seit
40 jahren ist herr namens name mit polo
hofer verbunden
ihr heimatort hat den beiden berühmten
söhnen in ihren liedern einem platz
gewidmet das beton klavier spielt auch
ihre erfolgreichste gemeinsame
komposition alperose
[Musik]
deswegen ja das mag ich nicht
also wird außerdem das spiel fertig
sowie fruchtig und der durch die quasi
die emotion verdammten sockel das
spricht für die sommerzeit so solang
show bekommt
wenn du das universum wo eigentlich
improvisieren mitspieler ins rennen
ich würde
[Musik]
aber ich glaube es ist einfach so
henry volksgut zum anfassen sollte kunst
machte
[Musik]
mit du bist mit
aber nicht
rumpel stets die urväter des minder
trocken die beiden alphatiere hofer nach
sieben jahren löst sich die band auf
wüste art und weise auf auch fast 40
jahre nach dem aus ein schwieriges thema
ja dass ich aber dass man ihn drüber 0
das ist irgendwie lachen hat dieses werk
das eine jahr stetig geklagt dass sturm
zur chemie um hoffen
ob sie da weil die schweizer sascha und
expressiver tag ist er jemand ist über
das schöne wetter zu werden fleißig noch
zum bruch von der band war nicht das
klinische immunologie überstehe ich
sagen siehst dann kommt und es mit rot
vor allem bei der generation über das
was machen
panahi war bei rumpelstilz zusammen mit
polo hofer sie haben so bekannte lieder
geschrieben wie der neue kiosk oder bin
ich keine bank oder der die verteidiger
und so jetzt hat hanna eine eigene band
die hanery amman band und was wirst du
singen
da wird es auch nochmal übersetzen baby
come back to you das heißt also baby ich
komme bestimmt mal zu dir zurück hanery
amman band baby a compact
zufrieden
[Musik]
mursi
auf seinem weg zurück
das wie
do
[Musik]
kraft und max
si
andere habe ich noch nie gehört was ist
das für ein name decke lassen schweizer
übernahme ein schweizer über das heißt
das ja das einfach namen cocktail
das ist definitiv vom um dort um so das
es verstand die airline air france auf
international
das ist immer die groß spruch mit einer
große firmen der internationale qualität
und aus und youtube groß ist und dass
alles super aber irgendwie als ein
fachgebiet zur sache endlich ziehen
alte geschichten aber man will vorwärts
schauen im studio falter seit monaten an
seinen instrumentalen musik
kompositionen
bald sollen sie hinaus aus seinem
kleinen reich im untergrund heraus zu
seinen fans auf die bühne
[Musik]
ich musik mache die letzte phase
das heißt es dass ich das ist
erschreckend wenn sie auch sehr
kritischen schlussmann uche
[Musik]
premiere in interlaken
heimspiel
nervosität
ja
hanery amman ist unzufrieden mit der
vorbereitung
auch wenn es nicht so aussieht die
sticheleien sind im ernst
der chef lässt die band unterschwellig
seine schlechte laune spüren
nach dem sommer
das ist klar
also und sorge dass wir mit 50 bildern
versehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
doch spätestens dann wenn sich ans
klavier setzt scheinen alle sorgen
verflogen
gehen sie auch in der leichtigkeit
seiner melodien
es ist wohl tatsächlich so wie er selbst
sagt
musik ihre kraft sie ist leben seiten
[Musik]